bonzai kitten lead singer Tigerlily
marlane and her boys celebrating the
release of their new album at a Berlin
Club
my lane puts on a great show and it's so
much fun I love this music and I love
the lyrics it's really great I didn't
expect something like that before I cuz
I didn't know about bonds they kiddin
we love it so much they're highly
motivated and have a lot of fun doing
what they're doing
I do just water
Oh
the for Berliners call their musical
style kill Billy and it's meant to knock
the fans dead
does mystics is the most important thing
the songs have to work live on stage
it's the greatest joy when you've
created something that goes down well
with the audience and they hand that joy
right back to you the conference box I
kitten at home in Berlin's Kreuzberg
district the band was formed in 2005 and
the current lineup have been together
for two years originally influenced by
psychobilly the band has since broadened
its musical horizon fans include punks
and psycho Billy's along with everybody
else we don't want to be forced into any
particular draw because a dresser has
lots of different drawers and curious
people open more than just one
they've released two new videos with pop
sounding tunes here's me myself and wide
and here's hardcore about you forget all
about man
Banzai kitten lyrics vacillate between
stories of lost love and socially
critical topics music make music and
write these lyrics because I want to
sing I have a need to express myself and
it just has to come out and I want to
communicate with people so I have a mic
in my hand and I write lyrics because I
think people are listening to me so I
don't want to talk about the bright blue
sky the bad works hard to make music a
full-time job
they played more than a hundred concerts
across Europe in the past four years and
occupy yourself is the band's third
album release inside the new album has
been praised from all sides so I
wouldn't call it our big breakthrough
things are going well we still have a
long way to go the band was in top form
at their release concert in Berlin and
they'll be hitting the festivals in
August